Nutan - for the snap he's got Colin
Smith coming on a rush and here's a
throw-in ership kicked off at the 9 yard
line
there is the 2013 season is a great
season a lot of big steps taken but it
ends in disappointment and I didn't have
my scholarship no more I was empty it
was like I did a whole 180 and instead
of being that guy that people was like
maybe like an idiot can blew away the
best opportunity I had in my life and to
lose that and all I lost my whole
identity everything that I valued in my
life got taken away there's something
about your life it's gotta change
something that's deficient it's no
longer suitable for your course of
action you've hit the wall someplace
you've looked in the mirror too many
times and haven't smiled you want to
change the situation move from where you
are the journey is not easy before you
start that journey mentally you must
fuel yourself with the right reasons the
right fuel to sustain the entire journey
everyone's hot off the start but after a
month or so into it a couple weeks into
it with the wear and tear and the cria
starts to hit she start losing focus on
the horizon do you not you get calling
away in the daily hiccups the ups and
downs and the wear and tear he
focus on the speed bumps the daily
activities losing sight of their true
purpose and you lose sight of the
purpose you get too much value of what
the pain is today we always invest today
sacrifice today for tomorrow's
betterment if we don't know that
betterment is the one factor what we're
really doing it for we can't win this
war guys in order to be successful
it's the wonk factor you have a capable
body to do whatever you want
you've a sound mental
once you find out you want the garlis
what it is then you combine the mind and
the body together that's when life gets
exciting guys stories of inspiration
with a person overcomes the odds when
you see the good man pump the brakes put
your hands together and give credit
where to do remember that name of the
person that overcame the odds you're
that same person you're gonna use it
your own battle one day when you hit
rock bottom
and you feel like the world's and
monkeys on your back Murphy's hitting
you down every single step the music
it's pretty that one more step forward
that makes all the difference it's me
I've got to make it happen it's not over
until I win
let me tell you something you already
know the world ain't all sunshine and
rainbows it's a very mean and nasty
place and I don't care how tough you are
it will beat you to your knees and keep
you there permanently if you let it but
it ain't about how hard you hit it's
about how hard you can get hit and keep
moving forward how much you can take and
keep moving forward that's how weird it
is done now if you know what you're
worth the glottic tell what you're worth
but you gotta be willing to take the
hits and not pointing fingers saying you
ain't where you wanna be because of him
or her or anybody cowards do that and
that ain't you
you're better than that it'll crunch
strongly and I ever wanted to imagine
the only way to know how strong is to
keep testing
champions keep blowing when they don't
have anything left in their tank that's
the difference between the grapes that
battle-ax separates them when they don't
have no more when it's over when they're
tired when they're frustrated when
they're ready to give up when they spent
their last dime that's when they get
started it's when you have nothing left
it's when you've depleted all your money
when all your energy go when you have
nothing left that's when it's Showtime
what if we have that kind of attitude
the cars repossessed nobody believes in
you you've lost again and again and
again the lights are cut off but you
still looking at your dream reviewing it
every day and say to yourself it's not
over until I win
when you want to succeed as bad as you
want to
and you ain't got nothing left in your
pay you got to think about the people in
your life that you're doing this for and
then if you can think about them you can
go one more mile you will go one more
day at work the truth is you gotta find
something within you gotta believe in
yourself get something you already a peg
laughter you keep it on your head if you
lose at least you try I fail it's ten
times more a man then someone said what
it is what it matter what